hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
what is today February 13th
2023. holy [__] it's the day before
Valentine's Day that [__] made up
[__] [__] holiday where a man has
to celebrate his woman and she doesn't
have to do [__]
I love it huh are women talking about
that women are talking
oh my God I have to go see that movie
women are talking
only white women could be victims in the
1800s while simultaneously owning slaves
sorry I have no idea what that movie's
about I just know the time period
um anyway uh welcome to the podcast I
hope you guys all had a nice weekend I
know most of you did most of you guys if
you will like me how great was it
yesterday if your team wasn't in the
Super Bowl actually I should say didn't
make the playoffs because you know
you've long since like been like I I get
it it's not us this year and then he
could just enjoy the I don't think I've
enjoyed a [__] Super Bowl like that
in a long time
and I was joking with uh
my father-in-law going like you know
it's just kind of nice I kind of love
that the Patriots aren't in this so now
I don't have to die a thousand deaths
it's kind of nice that they're not in it
and he goes well I think you're going to
have that feeling for a long time
and we both laughed and started to cry
um
but I sat down yesterday I had no
[__] clue what was going to happen
I just wanted to see a great game I
thought uh Kansas City was going to win
I thought they were going to cover but I
wanted to see the Eagles win
and uh what a [__] game that was it
was a great game I know there's a lot of
people upset with that call at the end
they're like what though you can't do
you can't
you can't you can't
do that
yes he held the receiver not once but
twice but you cannot make that call
right there and I love all the people
that are actually in football
who are talking who played that game who
I'm who are talking about it going like
you know it's just a shame they [__]
people out of overtime
and all of this [__] this is my number
one not my number one it's in my top
five pet peeves is when there's a call
at the end of the game and everybody
ignores the first 59 minutes of the
[__] game everybody ignores wait a
minute
wait a minute how did we get here
how is this game tied
how in the [__]
have you scored 35 or 35 [__] points
and this game isn't over
or whatever the [__] score was right
I mean
I think it's very easy to sit there and
look at that that play and then
automatically assume that KC was not
going to score
if they don't make that call
it's easy to assume that if it goes into
overtime and then the Eagles would have
won or whatever
this is my hot take
from a [__] unathletic [__]
freckled titted man here
the Eagles never should have been in
that position at the end of the [__]
game okay the Kansas City Chiefs could
not have done more to lose that [__]
game
the time of possession the amount of
first downs
the Eagles should have put them the [__]
away they didn't Kansas City was nice
enough to miss a field goal they were
nice enough to show up with the
quarterback with only one good leg the
Eagles [__] his leg up even more
before the half the the the guy the
purse thrower he got he's [__]
Mahomes
the man is in agony
you got him on the [__] ropes and you
let him off the hook
how many [__] delay a game penalties
did the Eagles Take
they let up not one but two defensive
touchdowns one of them the stupid rules
was nice enough to bring back remember
[__] Jalen hurts throws the ball the
guy catches the ball and the corner does
his job separates him from the [__]
ball runs it in for a scar
he didn't catch it long enough he has to
say one Mississippi two Mississippi
and then you can hit him and separate
him and then it's a [__] catch
all right and all you guys going oh it
wasn't your coach wasn't a catch oh yeah
if you threw if you threw a baldy a
little toddler son and it was like that
and he caught it and then your your
older brother came and he bumped into
him he dropped the ball you'd still be
like nice catch it was a nice catch son
I'm proud of you
the [__] Eagles let up the longest
punt return
in Super Bowl history
I mean I don't know what to tell you
here your defense let up more than 30
[__] points that's you had a 10 point
lead and you you just
you let it get away from you
I I think Jalen hurts played an
unbelievable [__] game
the throws the adjustments AJ Brown was
making
was amazing but like there was no
[__] reason
how about like Travis Kelsey
you know you didn't think they were
going to throw to him the [__] guy
was wide open the whole first half
never should have been in that situation
it sucks that they made that [__]
call when they made it but like he did
hold them I've seen like guys who are in
football going I mean yeah he he held
them but yeah you know you can't make
that call there it's like okay so you
can hold there
like what the [__] are we supposed to be
doing here so
I don't know
I just feel like uh
you can't you can't put it on that
that one call you the Eagles should not
have been there they dominated first
downs they dominated time of possessions
probably yardage two I would think
and somehow in the end Kansas City is is
in there your special teams [__] you
so I mean I don't know that Pacheco kid
was running
all over hell
by the way wearing Tyree kills old
number and then in the meantime nobody
really saw a story which was Casey was
just disrespected all year Tyreek Hill
leaves everybody goes there's no [__]
way they're gonna do [__] myself
included we're all like oh my God
Russell Wilson went to Denver
right
you got what's his face down there in
San Diego nobody in in and there was a
minute people were talking maybe the
Raiders will do something
everybody overlooks the Chiefs and then
they went out and they [__] won the
thing again so congratulations to the
Chiefs
uh somehow pulling out that game
I mean I can't say somehow they play
great Patrick Mahomes played great
the Eagles played great it was a great
game I just hate that that call was in
the end so now everybody can sit there
and be like oh that's because Patrick
Mahomes is the prom queen yeah he is the
prom queen
he is the prom queen there's always
going to be well there wasn't prom
queens when I was a kid you know you
could beat the [__] out of quarterbacks
but you know ever during the whole Brady
era Tom Brady was the prom queen Peyton
Manning was the prom queen before that
at the Rival high school they're all
that you know it's an Entertainment
Sports League they're gonna protect
people like that but he
the Eagles never should have been in
that [__] position you should have
put him the [__] away
you should have put him the [__] away
and you didn't I'm sorry
I'm sorry that's that's just uh just you
know it is it is what it is
and uh you know I don't know everybody's
probably gonna cry about that
last thing I mean as much as Patrick
Mahomes was the prom queen what about
the Eagles coach I mean how much camera
time did that guy get in the first half
they weren't trying to make that guy a
star in case because when it was looking
like the eagles were going to win
anytime even if it was an incomplete
pass by Kansas City they'd cut to him
going you know doing the incomplete
thing
and I'm sitting at home like I get it
the Eagles coach is happy when something
good happens for the Eagles
you know what I I don't need to see that
what am I sitting here thinking that
he's not happy so I mean there's a
little bit of that too
all right
they covered their bases
they did feel good stories about both
quarterbacks
try to make both of them little
tear-jerker stories there's Brothers
playing in the game they did all of that
[__] that they do before the Olympics so
then by the end of it you don't know who
to root for
right
I thought it was a great game I thought
that guy did hold the receiver
two times I'm when I watched the play I
was just like wow that that ball was way
off and then they showed the replay I
was like oh that's why
then everybody's like what
yeah when you hold the guy
I saw an analyst go literally like yeah
I mean yeah he held the guy but you
can't call that there it's like why not
why can't you call that there
so you're allowed to hold in the end of
the [__] game I don't get this is a
thing I don't have a dog in this fight
all right and uh I can't stand you know
I'm just so happy that Mahomes didn't do
a forward lateral so I didn't have to
listen to the announcers go like oh my
the greatest three-yard [__] did you
see what the [__] he did they just lose
their minds and they've been losing
their minds about Patrick Mahomes since
his first Monday Night Football game
where I remember that guy was going like
I hope you appreciate what it is that
you're seeing here and the guy was
basically just having a good game
and that was when but they were in a
panic because Peyton mannick has had
just retired and Tom Brady was always
like Well when the hell is he going to
retire they had no idea that he was
going to go on for like another six
seasons so that's what they do so now
he's the new guy he's definitely the new
guy but you know
he showed up with one stiletto heel
broken off and you know and then the
prom queen showed up limping
you know
you had him and you let him off the hook
I'm um my condolences to Eagles fans
uh but you know you can't let up more
than [__] 30 points but granted so
did the Chiefs I mean both defenses
didn't play well right we can say that
but the kids Kansas City defense did
score a touchdown or two they only gave
him one
how that isn't a catch I'll just never
understand how you can throw a ball to a
guy and he [__] catches the thing now
didn't catch it for long enough he's not
bobbling it he just catches it
um they also gave that Eagles uh that
catch you know where the guy bobbled it
and would put it up near his helmet why
that was a catch I have no [__] idea
when they called back the other ones so
I don't know
all right bill you made your point
um
so there you go congratulations to the
Kansas City Chiefs winning their third
their third Super Bowl I'll tell you
what annoyed the [__] [__] out of me
though was in the end of the game they
say to Patrick do you consider this is
this a dynasty this is a dynasty
is what a dynasty
we haven't won in three years and we
lost a Super Bowl so basically now you
can win a Super Bowl
lose a Super Bowl not to win the next
year and then win the next year for two
titles in four years is now considered a
dynasty I'll tell you this when the
Patriots won in 2001 lost in 0-2
didn't you know didn't make it there no
two and then one in o304 when they said
it was a dynasty I said that was
[__] when I was growing up you had
to win three in a row
all right now we're in the [__]
t-ball era you can't hit the quarterback
so you can basically win one
lose one but he came so close right not
even be there the next [__] year
losing the AFC Championship game and
then win the next year and then they're
throwing around the dynasty word I I
don't agree with that
all right the last Dynasty I saw
was the New York Yankees
when they won in uh 98 99 2000.
and then the Lakers
you know asterisk pile on team you know
well wait the Yankees were also piloted
but not 98 99 2000 they were whatever
it's it's a whole new thing it's it's an
Entertainment Sports League gambling's
legal it's it's it's all out the [__]
window at this point I think that you
should you should give a [__] as much as
a free agent does
here's my question
um and by the way I did have a double
shot of espresso so if I'm talking a
little fast here all right
um
what about Tyree kilf do you think it
was worth it
to go down there
to Florida
I mean they did have a good season till
everybody got hurt
their quarterback got hurt
what would you guys choose you already
have a Super Bowl ring you get a big
contract no state taxes
masks or vaccines right down in Florida
but alligators
alligators
it's cocaine
some of the hottest women in the world
do you stay in Kansas City
huh
maybe he got sick of the prom queen
maybe he knew that no matter what he did
on the field he was never going to be
prettier than Patrick Mahomes
that even though Patrick only [__]
threw the purse three yards and Tyrique
then turned around and ran the other 97.
that they were just going to be like to
have the intestinal fortitude to throw
the purse at your own End Zone I mean
that's just I mean you can't teach that
I hope you guys appreciate
yeah
meanwhile Tyreek Hill is out running the
[__] jet the military jet flyover at
the beginning of the [__] game you
think it was you think they give a [__]
it must bug him on some level
when Dr Fernie Pacheco was wearing his
number who at the whole game when they
kept saying Pacheco
that name just popped in my head Dr
Fernie Pacheco
that was from a long time I hate how my
computer just reminded me that tomorrow
is Valentine's Day
just to let you know tomorrow is
Valentine's Day
uh let me see here doctor
I think it was 30.
but checo
let me see what the [__] is to see
Pacheco something like that
oh there he is
Dr Fred was a physician at quarter man
oh that's right
for world heavyweight boxing champion
Muhammad Ali that's all I heard growing
up Dr ferdy Pacheco how is the champ
feeling
you know when I was a kid
a Pacheco
was like a 60 year old dentist with
coffee breath
and now I just love that that name came
back Pacheco how about that hit he took
too huh
good Lord it was a great game
um
sorry if I came a little hard on the
[__] Eagles fans I was just going
back and forth with like Versi
and he was saying even this guy said it
even that guy said it you can't make
that [__] call there
you know I mean you can't make that call
of course they can they can call 30
something falls on the Celtics in a game
seven in [__] 15 on the Lakers they
can do whatever they want their
entertainment leagues
oh we can't have the Celtics win two two
years in a row I mean we got to get this
Lakers [__] Celtics thing going again
we'll look the other way when Kevin
McHale gives us Kevin Garnett for nobody
um
anyway but I thoroughly enjoyed it we
had Kansas City Barbecue we had Philly
cheesesteaks
and then root beer floats
and uh
I had a nice low-key barely anybody over
at my house
uh Super Bowl party
and uh you know the first 10 days of the
month had gone
so I'm back to being Billy bad boy
so I had uh I had my little nice I had a
double espresso with the cigar
I'm telling you guys you got to do this
just just be a [__] choir boy for the
first 10 days of the month you have no
idea how good the first cup of coffee
tastes after that it's it's like being
reborn
[Laughter]
is this [__] too low why is this damn
thing
I swear to God like something always
comes in and [__] with the volume
maybe I got to be doing it right
I got a roach in here that doesn't like
my podcast
um
anyway um so that's it now
I will say this I really like the Eagles
coach
um
and I thought he uh
I just don't know how the [__] they lost
that game if you look at it on paper
when they they had all of those yards
all of that [__] time of possession
um
and Jalen hurts how about some of those
[__] throws he was making
and the catches AJ Brown's adjustment on
that that first long touchdown between
those two Defenders
and I don't know I thought you know it
sucks that you know he was switching the
ball from one hand to the other and it
caused a touchdown
um but this is this is the upside to
this I think the Eagles come back
um
I think they come back I think they got
everything and that they're going to win
another one I was got to be honest with
you I was really hoping that they were
going to win because when
I really enjoyed watching their
celebration that the first time they won
it even though they beat my team there
was nothing funnier than that [__]
guy running down the subway platform
and he bumped into the pole and sort of
rolled towards the train and everybody
for half a second I'd be like oh [__]
did that
they went from like absolute Euphoria
the Eagles finally did it to like oh my
god did we just see a guy die it's just
like
I don't know
it [__]
I've been there
I've definitely been there as a sports
fan I actually talked to my buddy the
other day I said I don't think I will
ever get over those two Super Bowl
losses to the Giants I've done uh a lot
of work to try to block it out but I've
kind of learned during my time off
this is such a weird thing that I've
learned I learned that sadness is
actually an emotion
I never viewed it
as an emotion I just have viewed it as I
almost viewed it like it was the bully
that I didn't want to fight and I was
just of oh I'll walk around this side of
the school and uh it just it doesn't go
away
but uh you know when I was feeling all
you know
Melancholy Had the Blues whatever you
want to call it I just sat in it
I just said [__] this I'm not gonna uh
you know go fill up my day I'm gonna
play drums and I'm gonna fly helicopter
and I'm gonna go for a hike and I'll do
a french lesson and then I'm not doing
that I'm just gonna [__] sit here on
the back porch in in this and just be
sad and I gotta it was one of the most
healthiest things I've ever done
this I'm talking to men here because we
try to avoid this I just sat there and I
was sad and I tried to figure out why I
was sad I figured it out
and
I just honored it
and I just stayed in it for like a day
and a half
and then you kind of you just kind of
come through the other side of it
you know it's like a leg cramp
it's kind of kind of just kind of go you
know
get through it but now like I understand
it so now it isn't like this masked
thing that's approaching me
I know what it is and I know I know
what's behind it
and I could just sort of sit there and
be like oh I guess those feelings are
coming up again and then just actually
experience them
and uh it's just done great for my it's
great that's a great thing to do if you
don't want to
if you don't want misdirected anger
when you know you try to run from that
[__] then later on that day when you're
with your wife and her relatives are
over
you know you want salt on this uh
yeah I'd like some salt did you say you
wanted salt yeah
all right Jesus what the [__]
like that stuff happens less
and then I've been doing this thing that
I saw and I got confirmed
um by someone else who isn't really a
doctor but that whole you take a big
inhale
and when your lungs are filled up you
take a another quick one
through your nose and then you exhale
you do that a couple of times and I
guess it's been shown to drop the stress
in your body and uh
I do that when I drive now
I did that when that guy was yelling and
he was sort of spitting
on me and my wife
when I turned around and I told him to
you know
to stop in so many words
um
I was sitting there you know when you
start squeezing the water bottle
the anger's coming up you're like hey
maybe I should try and see some of that
[__] that I learned in that taibo class
actually works
I mean how long do I really get to fight
this guy the Security's right there this
fight's Gonna Last all of eight seconds
as long as I get the first couple in
I'll take a few to the side of the melon
I'll tuck my head down I'll take a few
just a [__] hit him once and I just
went
and I did it twice and I was just like
I don't want to [__] do it why would
I do that you know this guy's he's from
Greece the other guy's from like Germany
or something they're [__]
they're watching the Los Angeles Lakers
I mean they they are experiencing
America they should be ridiculously
excited all right he's not spitting on
purpose he's just hammered
all right if you just walk away from
this [__] moment
okay
in an hour
you're never going to see these people
again and you can get into an Uber
with your wife
not have her bail you out of jail
not have to worry about getting sued and
just get the [__] out of here
oh oh let's let's you know get out of
the ego here Bill not have to go to the
hospital because you were fighting
somebody half your [__] age
that still has all this testosterone
I love how I just assumed that I was
gonna win against him and his other
friend they were in the prime of their
[__] life I really am an [__]
um
but we know this all right so anyway uh
I know I came I shouldn't have come in
that hard against the Eagles I thought
it was a great
[__] game and I just I'll
the [__] Eagles have an unbelievable
quarterback
and they have a great coach
and they have a great team and I think
that they're going to be there and uh
contrary to my one bad show that I had
everybody thinks I hate Philly I don't I
actually
love that City
and I think the people are hilarious and
I was talking to a buddy of mine
was saying that they actually and this
is this is this comes from a place of
Love Brotherly Love they actually out
Meathead the Meatheads from the state of
Massachusetts which is a really hard
thing to do
and uh uh I love a meathead
you know
I never Vibe with the Midwest
you know I just they remind me of
Canadians where it's that being nice but
there's this passive aggressiveness
underneath it
uh I love the South
um I don't know I just said something
about the pace down there
I love The Duality of how they like to
chill
but they also like to make their cars go
ridiculously fast
you know
they're like super nice and then they're
also in a white supremacist group but
just to push pull them and I'm kidding
um they're not all in it
uh yeah
I never vibed with the uh
the Hostile Pacific Northwest liberal
they never used to be like that they
used to be earthy crunchy and then
somewhere they just became these [__]
belligerent
uh somewhere around the time
when white liberals started drinking
Pabst Blue Ribbon that's when it really
went off the rails
you know
when they were all college educated and
they were like let's let's pretend we
[__] up in school and got a state job
and sat around drinking Pabst Blue
Ribbon that [__] swill
let's pretend we [__] work for a
living and not you know try to build a
website or an app whatever the [__] it
is what am I even talking about right
now I don't know
um all right
did I did I did I kind of do did I do it
justice that that's my take on the Super
Bowl
um
there's always going to be the [__]
the Wayne Gretzky that the league is
gonna [__] protect there is always
going to be that type of [__] but when
you got him on the ropes you know you
gotta [__] finish him off and they
didn't they let him back in the goddamn
game
and uh and now there's no football
there is no football but you know what
we do have Moto GP starting up
formula one is starting up March Madness
is coming up
you got all those ACC finals and all of
the SEC finals and all of that [__] to
get into the big dance it's going to be
great then before you know it baseball
is here I know a lot of you guys don't
like baseball because you know they
don't put you up on the Jumbotron enough
and the [__] DJ doesn't play
throughout the entire [__] game
whatever the hell it is that's missing I
love baseball
um
actually watch this Instagram clip of
highlights of uh
Nolan Ryan
I know we started off on the Mets but
like to me Peak Nolan Ryan was when he
was on the [__] Houston Astros
with those great 1970s uniforms the ones
that the great J.R Richards wore
um
to me that was like you know 104 mile an
hour fastball Nolan Ryan you know they
had this whole clip of watching guys
that like their knees buckling when he
throws this ridiculous curveball like
they're ready to jump out of the way and
the ball curves back in for a strike
and like I would say 60 of that was his
curveball and the other 40 percent was
they knew that you know this guy
you know if I'm crowding the plate we'll
throw it at my head and I think he threw
it enough guys
that everybody was worried about that
when they went up there and those were
the [__] days
when a pitcher went out like a power
picture like that went out there and the
other team was scared shitless
the whole [__] game
and if you crowded the plate he threw
one right at your [__] head
and if he hit you he hit you
the benches didn't clear
I guess maybe sometimes it did but not
really it was just
like a power picture really could
command the game back then uh like the
level of control that he had over the
game was insane
um all right let's do the reads here for
this week growth
have some resolutions
have some resolutions to be more
sustainable
uh make it easy and start with the
eliminating single-use Plastics
Grove collaborative is here with
reusable swaps to make a lasting impact
at home for your family and the planet
thank God there's companies like this
trying to make a dent in the mess that
we're making and leaving for our
children and everybody else after a new
year means a fresh start and a chance to
change the way you care for the planet
now is the perfect time to make your
home healthier happier and more
sustainable a new year means new
commitments to those we care about
family and Planet included if you've
been wanting to make more sustainable
choices for Home Care Beauty and more
start today with Grove collaborative
ready to make 2023 the best year yet for
your family and the planet start a
sustainable Revolution at home with
Grove collaborative and Shop over 150
brands that make a real impact Grove
carries hundreds of products aimed at
replacing single-use Plastics across
your home and personal care routine and
by 2025 Grove will be a hundred percent
plastic free
it's amazing I hope I hope more
companies do this
um like Groves company concentrated
cleaners and refillable glass bottles
they're friendlier to the planet and
twice as effective as the leading
natural Brands join over 2 million
household Brands already shopping
sustainably in growth yeah and
everything tastes better in glass as
opposed to plastic if you got kids they
usually make some sort of koozy thing
that you can put over it
you know so God forbid if they drop it
there's not a problem
um I think we're going to do it
everybody I think we're going to turn
this around
I'm believing in it because I have to
all right because other than that
it's too depressing all right join over
2 million households already shopping
sustainably at Grove go to grove.com
bird today to get a free Starter Set
worth up to 50 with your first order
plus shipping is fast and free get
started right now at growth.com
grove.com
all right
oh look who it is everybody it's all zip
[Music]
you know one of the biggest hiring
challenges for 2023 is starting out uh
standing out to Top Talent
job Seekers want more everything from
remote working conditions to an easier
application projects process to a better
snapshot of what your company culture is
like Jesus Christ employees are
ridiculous now
they're all everybody's acting like
they're a number one draft pick well
what does my cubicle look like
um how can you break through the Clutter
and attract the most qualified egomaniac
candidate for your business well you can
do it at Old zip
my map
now right now you can try for free at
ziprecruiter.com how to zip help you
stand out for to the uh to the right
candidates see if recruiters technology
sends you can great candidates for your
job and you can send a personal invite
to your top choices to make an impact
they also make it easy for candidates to
apply to your job instead of filling out
a lengthy application they can apply
with just one click I don't want to have
to fill out a whole thing
to help your job catch the eye of I mean
is that the kind of person you want to
hand you want to hire somebody you can't
even [__] fill out an application
because it's too long
yeah back in my day you sat down you
filled out an application and you liked
it
um the worst thing about becoming a
grumpy old man is actually knowing that
you're doing it you know I was actually
lost in it'd be a lot easier
um I actually wore a button-up sweater
on stage last night and nobody
questioned it
um to help your job catch the eye of
great candidates ZipRecruiter offers
attention-grabbing labels like urgent
training provided remote and more get
your job noticed by the best and
brightest candidates with zip recruiter
four to five employers who post on zip
get a quality candidate within the first
day see for yourself go to this
exclusive web address zip recruiter for
uh for free ziprecruiter.com
ZIP recruit I should spell out recruiter
z-i-p-r-e-c-r-u-i-t-e-r all right for
public school kids that was zip
recruiter not just recruiter all right
the smartest way to hire all right
all right
um all right disco vampire movie
um you know a buddy of mine actually
told me it was something love at first
bite or something like that
uh dear mozzarella legs
thanks for the twice weekly dump of
laughs and thought-provoking opinions in
between the misogyny and Dick jokes
I mean if that isn't the most accurate
description of my podcast
uh I don't know what is um over the
years long time listener here listening
to yesterday's podcast I was pleasantly
surprised to hear you mention Love At
First Bite a movie that I have a soft
spot for because I also saw that in the
70s at around seven or eight years old
on a flight to Europe weren't you a
fancy kid
uh it being the 70s my dad smoked at
least two packs during the flight
what a time what a time to be like I
mean there's something to be said to
just [__] die in a heart disease at
58. I mean just would you like would hey
can I offer you there was one answer yes
other than uh was it Jake LaLanne
whatever his name is
guy the juicer guy I've watched the
movie several times since then and think
it still holds up except some
regrettable scenes doesn't the the
vampire do like sort of a John Travolta
disco dance it was a less than
enlightened time
I gotta find that movie and watch it
again
that just seems like a great like
you know
everybody takes a gummy let's watch Love
At First Bite you know that movie where
they combined
Dracula with the Disco craze
anyways the film stars George Hamilton
Susan St James Richard Benjamin and
Artie Johnson shout out to Artie Johnson
and uh shout out to Ruth Buzzy too who's
still around
you know still working too by the way
and it's just plain silly Sherman
Helmsley and the actress that played his
wife Wheezy from The Jeffersons have a
fun Cameo as well
along with anything for a laugh mentally
the movie is also a great snapshot of
New York the New York I remember from
the 70s with the huge cars and general
scuzziness of the Ed Koch era that was
their mayor um I think I'm all in with
the cars in the realm of movies with
what the [__] endings I have to nominate
France at Ford Coppola's yeah because
this movie ends
spoiler alert I remember she turned into
a bat and the vampire was apologizing
going ah sorry I doomed you to eternal
life of murdering other human beings and
she was just like hey I could never get
my [__] together before Wednesday anyway
you know
sort of the first zip recruiter
candidate I don't want to like
fill out applications I'd rather [__]
get bit by a vampire in the realm of
movies with what the [__] endings I have
to nominate Francis Ford Coppola's the
conversation with Gene Hackman oh you
don't like the ending to that pretty
Shirley Feeney Cindy Williams and a
young Harrison Ford I still don't get it
well how do I talk well I'm going to
spoil the movie for people
um
basically that's the classic monster
movie where the monster you make comes
back to kill you when you're cowering in
the corner going no way I built you I
built you I said stop
like everything that that guy was doing
you know bugging these people places I
haven't seen them move in a long time
but it came back to him
where I'll have to watch that again to
to
be clear but like
his sins for doing what he did was that
now he lives in paranoia and he is
convinced
he's basically sentenced
to find that bug for the rest of his
life is what I thought
um
you know it's kind of a Lot Like Show
Business where uh remember Patrice used
to talk about Show Business he goes this
business makes you feel like the pimp
and then
a couple years in you realize oh wait a
minute no wait I'm still out here
walking the block
um I think that's kind of what happened
to him where he thought he was in the
pimp position and he realized that no
everybody
is somebody's [__] street walker
um anyway and for an underrated film you
should definitely check out the lovely
Nia
oh check out with the lovely knee I
thought Nia was in an uh
an underrated film how come I don't know
about it uh watch Martin Scorsese the
Age of Innocence from 1993 starring
Daniel Day-Lewis Winona
and uh Michelle Pfeiffer he said it's a
sleeper thanks again for the laps and
instead of [__] yourself treat
yourself to an espresso thank you I did
already this morning but you know it was
the worst though I actually also had a
vitamin C pack right before I did it I
didn't cleanse my palate so it didn't
taste as good as I wanted it to but
whatever
um I'm also down to like I just have one
a day I'm not gonna do that [__] where I
get all [__] wired
uh like an idiot all right I'm just
gonna enjoy it and that's gonna be it I
have a sense of self-control because I
take those 10 days off
people what I'm basically saying is that
I'm better than all of you I've done the
math myself and you guys weren't allowed
to add the numbers and in the end I feel
that I've come out on top all right
baseball caps outside of the city
why do these [__] things look so
small here
these little ripples here but on the
bottom they look big I'm talking about
the the cardiogram of my voice here
Cardiology screen here
um baseball caps outside of the city hey
Bill lots of love from Peru
isn't that nice I got to get down there
one of these days
I want to go to the I want to go to a
MotoGP
um race down there in Brazil that would
be amazing anyway I was listening to
your podcast while you were talking
about American football and you started
talking about how baseball capitals are
more prevalent
than any football related apparel
baseball caps I'm an idiot I thought you
were oh God I'm so stupid baseball caps
outside of the city not capitals
I just see the Caps that I think the
Washington Capital sorry lots of love
from Peru I was listening to your
podcast while you were talking about
American football and you started
talking about how baseball caps are more
prevalent than any football related
apparel I could bet at least in my
country that most people equate the
Yankees logo or the Dodgers logo look at
that with the city itself instead of the
baseball team
uh since baseball is not that popular
south of the Caribbean south of
Venezuela
um there's another I would love to go to
Venezuela I would love to go to Columbia
um anyways he says uh she says hope you
get the chance to visit Peru and maybe
see
Machu Picchu
although you probably you should
probably wait for the ongoing
manifestation to stop
all right that means there's some sort
of unrest uh have a great week and real
football is played with your feet
um listen nobody says you guys can't
enjoy your football why can't we enjoy
our football our version of it you know
um racist work event oh boy here we go
is it racist
hey Billy sunburn I work in a blacked
out
oh my God like the CIA this thing's
blacked out and the facility recently
sent out a newsletter regarding a
week-long event that they will be doing
for Black History Month they decided
that it would be oh boy
oh boy
oh boy here we go here we go
remember when that guy thought it would
be a good idea to drop turkeys from a
helicopter and he didn't realize that
they didn't fly and they all splattered
on the ground I feel like this is what
happens even when we we try to do
something nice for black people we're
still going to [__] it up all right here
we go
they decided that it would be a good
idea to challenge all of the employees
to a photo contest of us wearing our
African slash Caribbean attire
and the winners will be rewarded special
prizes
I'm calling this dress like a black guy
week
I would love to how did how could you
still be this stupid anyways I would
love to hear you rambling about massive
Mega Corporation absolutely failing
while trying to cater to the liberal
crowd as well as answer these two
questions I don't even think they're
even trying to cater to the
liberal crowd
I I think that this is honestly them
thinking that they're doing
they're making a difference
I don't think their heart isn't well
they're probably like well we got to do
something so people don't think we're
racist
I don't know
it's it's it's a it's
how do you undo all of this [__] all you
can try to do is as an individual is you
just try to be a better person other
than that I don't know what anyway so
the person says which is more racist
rewarding a white guy for dressing up as
a black guy or not rewarding a white guy
dressed up as a black guy after you told
him to
oh wow that's a good one
which is more racist rewarding a white
guy I don't think it's racist I just
think it's it's stupid
this isn't like racist it'd be racist if
they were making fun of them that this
is just ignorant
that they think that this is what they
should do they should probably you know
maybe hire some black people and try to
give them an opportunity so maybe
there'll be a few black people there
going like hey guy hey white guys this
is probably not a good idea hey White
Management
xnay on the uh dashike
um
I would say what is worse I would
probably say you know if there's some
white guy going like I'm not [__]
doing this this you guys are missing the
Mark here it's probably worse to punish
the person for not doing that but I
don't think that this company
uh
is doing this coming from a bad place
I'm at least I'm I don't know I don't
[__] who gives a [__] you know it's it's
close
all right and last but not least what
would you what would your wardrobe of
choice be for this event
thanks for the laughs and go [__]
yourself I know exactly what it would be
it would be that that uh black guy
felonious monk Little Jazz hat
you know the Little Pill Box
that Thelonious Monk would wear on top
of his head I would do that because Neil
pert also wore it so if I actually got
in trouble
you know for dress stressing like
Thelonious Monk I'll be like no I was I
was dressing like Neil Park and that
would be my alibi so I could keep my
cubicle
how'd you like that bam immediately had
the [__] answer
that's how [__] white I am I can't I
can I can weave my way in and out of
these 28 days
of Black History Month and still have my
cubicle in the end all right
psychiatrist's opinion for why you suck
at reading out loud
are you [__] kidding me
Jesus Christ it's that bad that we had
to bring a professional on here
hey Billy boy Freud you get it Sigmund
Freud I Am a Child and Adolescent
psychiatrist for some reason c-h-i-a he
had
capitalized working in a major city
so you know I'm not a mouth breathing
[__] at least on this topic here is the
link to my credentials I'm not clicking
on that [__] thing yourself involved
jackass
um to add to my professional experience
I mean how do I know this is you you can
just [__] send a link to anything
I brought a I brought the uh I broke the
deadlift [__] uh
clean jerk [__] thing whatever the
hell you called here's a link to me
doing it how do I know it's you all
right to add to my professional
experience I also personally have a mild
form of ADHD that was never formally
treated until later in life but
definitely has led to issues with
forgetfulness and organization
throughout my life
all right first of all I just want to
let you know that I'm offended that you
feel because you work with Children and
adolescents that I'm not even adult
enough that's actually pretty [__]
accurate all right I get it
you act like a child you end up getting
a child psychologist to [__] figure
out what your problem is okay fair
enough
um
a common misconception about ADHD is
that it means you can't focus on things
that's not true as you yourself may have
experienced people with ADHD struggle to
focus on certain things but hyper focus
on other things that are complex and
sustain their interest yes I believe
I've talked about this and I think that
you're plagiarizing me from what you
listen to on the podcast
you know so you can you can [__]
continue to add like legitimacy to your
claims that you're a child an adolescent
psychologist
okay I would have believed that you were
the fact that you had to [__] give me
a linked
you know let's let's why don't we
analyze you what's going on with you
that you felt the need that you had to
send
your resume to me
you know what what let's let's talk
about that what's what's going on with
that like where's that coming from
you know talk about your childhood did
you feel that you're
parents built you up do you feel that
they believed in you and thought that
you could achieve things
did they not
is that why you sent me a complete
stranger your resume
because in a way I was you know because
this is my podcast I represented an
authority figure and dare I say a
parental
so to figure that that you went back to
being six years old again
and had to send me your [__]
trumped-up resume
a common misconception about ADHD is
that it means you can't focus
[__] that's [__] funny I can't focus
on things I just [__] literally took
a left turn and then came back and
started rereading what I already read
this hyper Focus often leads them to
forget or ignore other things they can't
do
forget or ignore other things that they
can't do okay so the issue with hdhd
isn't the inability to focus but the
inability to appropriate to appropriate
to appropriate allocate that Focus I
think you meant appropriately allocate
that Focus
yes I understand all of this I am hyper
focused when I fly a helicopter
uh when my wife is talking to me about
what our day is I'm looking at my phone
and also thinking about something I'm
not focusing on anything
um
yeah I I understand this stuff
this is like like don't ever let the
report or your your high school
transcript
like that isn't that isn't a reflection
of who you are it's a reflection of how
you felt about school
I finally figured that out because if
you just take it at face value like I'm
dumb I'm not smart it's like no I I
wasn't into this [__] I don't like
school it's way different than being
stupid
um does that make sense
um another common issue is that people
with ADHD have trouble keeping up with
how fast their thoughts are going and it
tends to present itself when reading
yeah I found if I actually slow down
I read much better I also [__] if I
get in my head and then I try to go even
faster it all goes off the rails
and I also think that when I'm reading
slowly it sounds way slower to The
Listener
let's try reading the rest of this
really slowly while reading the first
and second word your mind is already on
to the third and fourth word I've
already [__] it up it's already on to
the third and fourth I'm still stupid uh
you can read entire sentences and
paragraphs and by the end of it think
what the [__] did I just read yes or
when reading out loud you stumble over
your words yes because your mouth can't
keep up with your fast without with your
fast your thoughts are going you don't
you're not a [__] psychologist you
can't even write a goddamn email
or do you have hdad HD2 is that your
[__] excuse
this is an enigma I don't know what this
[__] guy is this sometimes get
confused with dyslexia although ADHD and
dyslexia do occur some together
sometimes
you're basically describing me I have a
little bit of that like when I look at
Billboards I think they say something
other than what they say the words don't
get jumbled up but they I just look at
the words and I think they say something
else uh meds and therapy can definitely
help severe forms
why do you need to help it
just you're [__] really smart your
brain's going too fast for this [__]
that you don't want to [__] read
why would you drug that out of you go
find something that holds your interest
you know
like Aviation or a pair of [__] tits
uh but there are plenty of people with
more manageable forms who adapt and
learn shortcuts and live full lives
without treatment I did that until I was
about 30.
hope this wasn't too hard for you to
read well maybe you shouldn't have so
many [__] spelling errors next time
Mr [__] resume Billy bird brain all
the best to you and the kiddos and Nia
thank you sir or ma'am um
yeah I I you know I got all that makes
sense to me other than putting people on
meds
uh I don't understand why you have to go
on meds because your brain is working
too fast
uh I think that you should seek out
something that
makes you interested that holds your
interest and focus on that and do that
for a living
and uh that's it
what is the problem um all right
Delicatessen
dear Billy French frowns you should
watch a French film called Delicatessen
don't research it and don't let anyone
spoil it for you well I just said the
name of it so now everybody's gonna
[__] tweet me the ending so that
there goes that I don't give a [__] I'll
still watch it um thank you I appreciate
that all right that's the podcast
everybody
um thank you guys for giving me uh
recommendations on movies and trying to
help me with my mental health
you know while subtly sending me your
[__] resume
not even subtly
um congratulations to the Kansas City
Chiefs winning their third Super Bowl
championship congratulations to Patrick
Mahomes with the very
gutty performance uh congratulations to
the Eagles in an amazing season
um
and
I don't see a Kansas City
you know repeat I don't see a dynasty
that they're claiming I don't see any of
that I actually I see the Eagles I see
the Bangles
and uh all of that [__] being a major
problem with that is what I feel I just
don't think that there's going to be I
don't know I just wish it would go back
to you have to win three in a row to be
a dynasty rather than just sort of
hanging around and winning one and then
not winning it for three years and
actually blowing one getting your ass
kicked
that's not a dynasty a dynasty is Jordan
right three in a row twice
the Yankees pick a period in their
career the Celtics the Lakers those are
[__] dynasties not the [__] Kansas
City Chiefs all right you can take that
and flush it down the [__] toilet
because uh I ain't buying it it's a lump
of [__] all right that's it go [__]
yourself
on Thursday
and now the long pause I gotta have this
clicker ready sooner bye